I'm passing the bolt
and the stage is yours thank you thank
you very much I really want to thank you
Chris and considina for inviting me and
having me in this Meetup really honored
that I'm gonna speak here
um yes so
I want to thank everybody here and
everybody watching in the future hello
future people
for attending this presentation and
taking the time so today I have prepared
for you
um a data engineering student
standardization framework in Python so
we're gonna go over and see what this is
all about
so the main highlights of this Meetup is
going to be two uh semi-live uh coding
demonstrations to practically show you
what I'm talking about
so who am I so my name is vasilis
murtakos I am a transportation civil
engineer
um from ntua Athens I'm from Greece I'm
also a PhD student and right now I work
for refurbed in Austria as a junior data
analyst
um I would really like to thank
um two of my dear colleagues
um Felix and Tina who
um part of the code that you're gonna
see in the next minutes is partially
written or modified or inspired or
um discussed with or buy them
so yes thank you guys really excited for
this
so what is this about
so most likely most of us are watching
this presentation are data professionals
or are interested in
um data manipulation so in the day
day-to-day uh professional
um life of a data professional like
analyst engineer scientist or otherwise
you would have to use some boilerplate
code in order to get through your tasks
most likely this code is has been used
in other tasks or projects by yourself
or other colleagues so a boilerplate
code for those who are not familiar is a
code that is repeatedly in use with
little to no modification so you would
reuse between projects without getting
it changed
so what would this code be we could be
referring to it could be referring to uh
authorization pipelines like authorizing
to Google cloud or other apis that you
might have
input output operations like compressing
decompressing and otherwise data
operations which we all know how much
pain you can have by working with dates
and date times
loading setups squaring in sqls which we
very regularly must do visualization
casting testing Etc et cetera so
the ambition of uh this this
presentation is to practically indicate
the steps and the benefits that are are
going you're going to have by
standardizing the most common processes
of your um daily uh work in your
organization in a producible manner and
in a data engineering framework so to
achieve this uh the plan is to have two
demonstration uh firstly a simple
stakeholder request to simulate it uh in
order to outline
um what are the cons of a quick and
dirty solution that you might do in this
occasion and after that uh to present
some additional more complicated
requests again fictional and simulation
uh to clearly indicate the benefits of
uh creating this custom data engineering
framework that I'm talking about which
is also going to be developed and
utilized in this live demonstration
yeah
did I skip anything no okay cool okay so
for the uh simple request we're gonna
just
um say that you have some stakeholders
and they ask you to provide them with
let's say a daily monitor of the amount
of sold products and their mean price
per country and supplier no big deal so
they also inform you that there is no
rush and you can do it in your own time
but you have like 30 minutes to do it
before a big presentation so
take your time so the specification for
these requests
um for this request is going to be the
following so firstly the transaction
data are going to be appended in a table
in Google's bigquery at midnight every
day so for those not familiar bigquery
is a fully managed by Google serverless
data warehouse that enables uh stable
analysis over like petabytes of data
it's a platform as a service
um the supplier data are manually
updated by your stakeholders in an Excel
file in your storage service of your
organization I'm sorry uh we use
SharePoint for example which is a
web-based collaborative platform like a
document management and storage system
um the results of this uh request of
this effort have to be integrated in a
table in your organization's database
could be in any SQL SQL database
um and so it has to be in this
organization in the organization
database so then it can be utilized by
your bi tool in my organization we use
looker which is a great tool it's a
business intelligence and data
visualization platform again developed
by Google we love Google
um it has also some other benefits you
can you have it has its own language
look ml it's an SQL based language and
it can Aid you to um create Dimensions
measures and then structure your data uh
create dashboards and all these nice
things
so it's important to incorporate this in
looker uh for example and then you you
are required to take a daily snapshot of
the raw data uh you extract every day
from this Pipeline and save it to Google
Cloud Storage which is just a
um a web service of Google for online
file storage
finally you want this or this uh process
this pipeline to be automated and
executed daily so you could do that for
example with um by utilizing Google's
Cloud functions
so to go for the first demonstration the
quick and dirty solution so the quick
and dirty means that uh it is a fast
solution it's not elegant it might not
be elegant or efficient or maintainable
for the long run but it's uh it's
working now and it's very fast so the
trade-off of speed might be less
readability less organizational
documentation Etc
so you will see in a minute that to
solve this uh very straightforward
problem the code required is actually
quite simple nonetheless to complete
this task you have to go through the
data engineering side that would be to
authorize to Google Google Cloud
platform to
um authorize to the directories on
SharePoint to access the Excel file or
files authorized to looker execute SQL
queries against bigquery and your
organization's database
upload files develop a cloud function
there are a lot of stuff so let me uh
jump to the um first demonstration
hopefully you do see now
um
the code can someone confirm that you're
seeing code and not presentation right
now
cool thanks
so yes so the first thing you might do
in this occasion is you would like open
a um
a notebook this is pycharm my ID of joy
of yeah of choice uh this is just a
regular Jupiter notebook
um so you would like
um import your a piece of your data set
and go through it so this is what I'm
doing right now
very nice
yeah anyway it doesn't really matter
sorry
yep so this is a gaggle data set this is
no data from my company disclaimer it's
just a Kegel data set a random one that
I'm using for this showcase
so you would just go through the data
that you have and I want to note here
otherwise nothing really matters here's
in this demonstration it's just as so of
a quick and dirty solution uh when I
open a data frame I like to lower the
columns and replacing dots and all that
so there is a reason why I'm saying this
keep an eye for it
um so you go through your data set so
there there's the suppliers one so I
randomly generated some of it fun fact
uh chat GPT helped me come up with some
names for some pliers so you just I just
go through some random suppliers and
um
assign them stock stock codes to match
the previous data frame again as I said
I like the columns to be like this you
have a point to make with this and then
you could do whatever else you would
need to do to for to finish this request
like merging or
um erasing some nulls and all that
um and then do the final group buys and
everything else that you might do to
finish it
yes make sure that you have the desired
Aggregates for the finalization of the
request
again I'm not going through every single
thing because it's really not important
so you would just go and wrap everything
into a function that would be the
function to do the entire request of
your stakeholders
and then you might write some tests and
since this is a quick and dirty
um solution the tests are like this so
let's say for example that we take the
revenue from another reliable database
and we compare it
to what we got here
um
of course the test pass because this is
a demonstration
so you're over the request part so this
is a function that you need to automate
these are a couple of tests that will
tell you that you're going good
so you would need for example now to do
the engineering side the engineering
side what would that be so you would
need to for example go over the effect
transactions table and get all the
things that you need from Google's
bigquery of course this is a fake
transaction thing so it wouldn't work
you need to go to the SharePoint folder
and write a pipeline for that you would
need to do what you already did so
monitor the transactions we did that
before and then save to Google Cloud
Storage create the SQL query to go into
your organizations database and then
update your
um looker table and all that so I didn't
fill up this uh last functions because
there's a way I'm going to show it to
you in a minute so that would be the
wrapping up of a quick and dirty
solution it can be done really fast and
it would work right off the bat
um
yes so well done you did it very fast
very efficient it works and Bravo so the
next obviously logical question to ask
yourself uh after this success would be
you know come on where's my promotion it
was so fast so efficient come on
nonetheless the stakeholders are gonna
be way up there is more so following
this dazzling success of your very fast
and efficient implementation the
stakeholders of your and other
departments are sliding in your DMs with
increased number of requests by the
minute so some of these could include
like adding alerts to this previous task
that you completed that would appear in
your company's
um messaging service you could be using
slack or for example we're using mother
most uh for sudden changes
um and other stakeholders and other
departments are asking you to
investigate in the same other same
manner other tables with different
characteristics Etc
and doing a similar pipeline
so there's a lot of things going on and
the fast and dirty Solutions are just
gonna be too much of a grind at one
point
so going on for the second demonstration
we're gonna go to the standardization
part so I'm gonna go Bullet by bullets
here to not confuse you guys so some of
the benefits from standardizing the most
common data pipelines is firstly
reusabilities you don't need to rewrite
the same code over and over again copy
and pasting
um modified pipeline files to different
projects and finding what the best
version of your past work was
um all your important tools and
pipelines I'm going to the second bullet
now all the important tools and
pipelines are gathered in a single
reference point you don't have to search
your local folders Etc next
um you can maintain this uh it will be a
repository so you can have a comment
history and you can easily uh go through
the development of this pipeline of this
standardization Pipeline and after that
we have reproducibility and flexibility
because we can have versioning
information
and different use case end users can all
accommodate their needs into this
centralization
after that you could uh it's something
you can share and collaborate with your
colleagues and peers uh it's something
that is that can't be well documented
and up-to-date one of the most important
things
um and the final two points is that when
you start a project having standardized
your most common pipelines you you kick
start the project with a very
significant and very reliable Head Start
and finally you can uh more easily
onboard the new team members so you can
quickly so you what are the basic tools
what are the basic pipelines to quickly
get them uh up and running in the team
so
what are the proposed steps uh for this
Meetup to
practically like you could do this today
tomorrow build your own simple data
engineering standardization framework
and use it in your day-to-day job so
I'm going to go through them in the
demonstration but to quickly
um tell you what I'm gonna do we're
gonna gather the most used data
pipelines and functions in a structures
and documented manner
because you have the time
um ability to do this you're structuring
it so you can't you can have good
documentation a good structure you're
not rushing into it uh we will add them
in a remote repository you could be
using gitlab GitHub for this
presentation I'm using my personal
GitHub you're gonna see about it uh but
it has obviously it has to be accessible
by your team to make sense for your
organization and then we're gonna make
this installable so we can grab it
whenever we want from whenever we want
like from a Google function from any
machine or
um virtual machine
um and another step would be to create a
template project which I'm a very big
fan of
um so that you every project that you do
or your colleagues on your teams can
have at least at this basis a common
code structure along with some basic
testing setup that like the bare minimum
I would say
um and then you could just clone the
project the template project install
your engineering framework and then you
have a very nice Kickstart to your uh
next project at hand
so let's go to the second demonstration
I hope I didn't tell you enough guys uh
already so let's go for step number one
I want to remind you that step number
one was to gather the most used data
pipelines and functions
so here I have
um this file this etl.pi file it's a big
file
um a most proper way would be to
separate all your different functions
you're gonna see here
in this structure that we have all these
uh classes which all represent like
as a tool in quotes
um so it is not really efficient to go
right there and import all these
libraries not really efficient but for
the sake of not having too many things
to to present here and confuse you guys
I put them all in one so I'm gonna go
through them really fast
so since you are gathering
um all your tools and pipelines you can
have everything you need here so an
important thing is logging so you can
have a logging setup exactly as you want
it so you don't have to copy and paste
the same file over and over again or the
same code to uh incorporate your logging
setup you can just go and get it right
right off the bat
side note for those who are not familiar
I'm gonna use data classes in this um in
this setup
I'm not gonna go in depth it's the same
as classes but with some less code
so another thing
uh that you have to do in every project
is the authorization pipelines as we
discussed earlier so you could have
um your secrets in Google for example
it's a very common procedure and
um then you could just
pick the um
the um secrets and the clients and all
that that you need to access your apis
so for example in our fake project we're
getting our fake looker secret and we
are accessing our looker clients our DCP
clients and our bigquery clients and
this is all right off the bat
and then we have SharePoint operations
reading and uh downloading files from
supporting SharePoint and uploading file
operations compressing decompressing
pickling
um looker operations are like uh
executing a query and download getting
it into a data frame and from a CSV
format getting uh look a little look
look is um a combination of
um measures and dimensions from looker
as I said before
it's never mind if you don't aren't as
familiar with looker it's just an
operation on this tool SQL operations
like
um uh creating an SQL
command from a data frame that you're
using in your script
um either by a plane string operation or
using SQL Alchemy or whatever else tool
you want
um we have gcp operations
matter most operations now modern most
operations are are messaging service as
I said before
bigquery operations daytime data frame
and everything else that you want to
include for example alerting
um so this is a a compilation of all our
uh important tools and pipelines that I
personally use and many of my colleagues
use in their day-to-day work and a big
Advantage as I said before is that you
can maintain this and document this and
have this in a single reference point
for so for example there is guidelines
here that you wouldn't take the time to
write
um in every single quick and dirty
solution
so what was the first step The Next Step
as we said is to add this uh at this
file
to a remote repository that can be
accessed by your team
so I'm I'm using my personal repository
so this is public you could go and
see it is one of the benefits of this
um presentation I'm able to share things
with you to kick start your own project
really fast
so there is nothing really sophisticated
here I just uploaded a folder here in pi
data ETL pipelines called ATL pipelines
and within it I have the same file that
I just showcased this one
and the only thing that it requires to
become a packaged both locally and here
in the repository is just this uh
Thunder and it init.pi file and then
there is double underscore file
um that and also I setup.pi which has
very minimal information uh the name of
the package really important the version
also quite important my major version
minor and paths that would be 1.0.0 most
common one then some other information
not really that important
um packages you could go for find
packages I just I had one so I just put
it there and then what this package
requires so you can see I have a lot of
requirements because again this is a
showcase
so I have this um package in the remote
repository as it was
um
yeah as it was step number two and I
have made it installable and it was step
number three now we have to create a
template project for our most common
code structure so that would be
something like this so
um
I'm actually gonna go through this uh in
ide so it's easier for you to see so I'm
gonna just
grab it and uh go and get clone it
so I'm just going to open a power cell
here and go get clone
yes so we can easily get into this
actually let me rename this because that
what you would do my
uh awesome
project
yes so you are in your awesome project
very nice let's get in here as well my
awesome project cool
so what do we have here let me open it
as in pycharm which is easier to see
there we go
okay
so
yes we're going to do that in a second
so we have our requirements we have our
git ignores we have everything that we
need to get started we don't have to
write it all over again getting nurse
um requirements tests anything so we
could have our code base undersource and
tests under tests so this is already
really nice it can save you some minutes
of organizing your files
um as you would normally do
so
um let's make this a project so we did
everything and we're going we're at step
number five we're gonna start a
Kickstart and and that engineering
project so what do we need to do let me
grab my cheat sheet here you're gonna
see it
um yep let's go back to this um
uh cell and let's do the following so
we're going to create a virtual
environment uh just for this
presentation so pay data
environment yes
just just to have a clean start you
could do this on your own environment
but just for the Showcase I'm gonna use
a clean one
so I'm in Windows so I have to do
something that if you work in Linux or
Mac you probably don't have to do
it's just to allow for this Activation
so we have our environment is right
there
and now we're going to just activate it
yes like this scripts and activate
for those of you not familiar with Git
it's um it's a way to keep track of what
you're doing
um I'm not gonna get into detail
um so we have an active
um environment here so
we can see that it is clean we just
created it yes
so
um what I would like to do now is to
um yes so another thing that I want to
show you is
yes so I have two requirements for this
presentation so one is with all the um
libraries that you would launch normally
use and the other one is pi test just to
have the testing infrastructure to use
the testing infrastructure that we have
and the other one is uh the packets that
we did before so the ETL pipeline that
we have uploaded before so the way that
it works is that we have this
um
it's the same URL that you would use in
git clone uh we are defining the um
yep the uh brands that we're using and
we're defining the module that we want
to use
so I'm gonna just go in and say pip
install
our requirements.edl
and it's going to grab everything
and install it
it's not gonna take too long I have
tested it
um
while this is working I we have another
job to do and that would be to
um
fix the git structure of this project so
um since you downloaded since you cloned
this from your template project it
carries the commits and it is connected
to
um your
project repository so this one what we
would like to do
go away
anyway yes what we would like to do
would be to have this by data demo so we
would like our awesome project to come
here so I'm just gonna copy this
okay this is installing
sorry about that yes so what we're gonna
do is this we're going to detach our
remote
so this is just to showcase the git
um side of this pipeline so we're going
to detach the origin
origin of it yes
um
we are going to remove the commit
history by doing git checkout
um orphan
or brunch uh New Branch
yes so this is now a new Branch with no
commit history we will uh see what we
are where we are we have all these files
that we need to
um
add we would not we don't want to add
the pi data environment there so
I'm going to add it separately
hit ignore yes
read me yep
requirements
source
and tests
so git status would be
um yep everything is ready to be
committed
so let's commit them so first commit of
this awesome uh
of awesome projects
yep
cool so now we have committed them and
we are in new brands uh we're going to
delete
the main brands
which we don't want
and we're going to rename our own Brands
um main yes
and now we will add uh do I have this
yes we're going to add the remote that
we want remote ads
origin
yes and just push it so push you into
origin Main
yep
so if this goes well
we're gonna have all our files right
here in our PI data demo which is cool
nice about on the back
so I'm done with the git let's go back
and see if this is installed it looks
installed Let's test it so the way to
test it it would be to go and do this
python does C and let's try to import it
ETL Pipelines
it works no error it works so we have
our packets
we have our project template we can now
uh go ahead and like test it
so we're gonna
use uh The Interpreter that we have
created this time all this time
a moment
what is the load yes let me add The
Interpreter yes cool
okay so let's go to Main and let's try
out a couple of things let me try this
so from ETL pipeline how did I call it I
don't remember since the moment
ETL okay
okay so that would be ETL
it's still indexing
just the second
yeah python likes to take its time
all right
there we go
nice now module ETL pipeline now it is
awesome
okay are we TTL pipelines right
um yes
so you can see that we have our logging
setup right out of the box right here
very easy to use
um we can actually also showcase
something else so again from medial
pipelines
ETL we could do a looker operation so
select from a fake table and from
nowhere this will fail of course but you
could see you can see how easy it is to
access this so you would go just look at
um looker Ops
and you could have your get looker look
execute query and you can have your own
documentation
um
all at your hands right like after three
minutes after you started your project
and there are many other things I'm
gonna just present a final one
um the alerting one so let me delete all
this so it's not a
yeah so you can understand what I'm
doing so yes ETL so alerting Ops and
matter more Ops let me fill out these
actually I don't so with this pipeline
this like 10 lines of code you have a a
ready exception Handler to add to all
your projects and it will notify your
um organization's Channel very
convenient very easy like in 10 lines of
code that you have already written and
done maintain
so that was all for the second
demonstration
yes
um
let me go to back to my yep so final
thoughts to close this presentation
um
it is really worth the investment of
tailoring and maintaining a data
engineering framework according to your
need to your and your team's needs and
most common pipelines and we will most
likely will definitely um I'm sorry pay
dividends and be of great value
um since as you get more senior and get
more time in this in your organization
you will have a constant stream of
similar requests and they would have
similar specifications
so in this presentation that we you've
just seen there was no like
sophisticated Ultra sophisticated code
or procedures like previous pipelines
with deep theoretical background but the
main ambition of it was to inspire the
professionals and enthusiasts to escape
their quick and dirty habits and provide
them with practical demonstrations and
steps as to really get started in
standardizing their own processes thus
helping themselves and their colleagues
um furthermore the content that you just
uh saw is available as I said to my
personal
um GitHub repository I'm gonna show it
one last time so it's vasilis murtakos
this ball dude
um paidera ETL Pipelines
um so the content that you just saw is
actively being utilized utilized by me
and I'm trying to
um
push it not push it um suggest it to my
colleagues and to help both me and my
colleagues in our day-to-day work and I
really hope that you can yield some
interesting ideas out of uh these steps
that are presented and the contents of
um these pipelines to structure your own
um tailored custom framework
so to close this two really interesting
coach boats to inspire you to build your
own standardization framework the first
one is uh the first three lines from the
Zen of python from Team Peters the
founder of the language so beautiful is
better the ugly explicit is better than
implicit and simple is better than
complex always simple is better than
complex and an observation from Taylor
Hogs uh co-founder of photo sharing app
called cluster uh he told us that from
his Decades of being developing this app
uh one of his biggest lessons as an
engineer was that novelty and
optimization are the enemy of durable
long-term code which most of the times
is true
so with that I really hope I didn't tell
you all too much
um I really want to thank you for your
time and attention and I'm open to
um any questions thank you very much
uh Vasily hi I just wanted to point out
that uh Christos left so I think you're
the the host now so if you want to stop
reading for for questions uh should I
should I stop the recording for
questions
I guess people would be more comfortable
maybe asking questions of course let me
just find out how to do it stop
recording easy
yes